avec nous pour en parler en direct donc
cyrielle cyril pardon d'allemands
chercheur à l'institut thomas ce mot
bonsoir série l'allemand merci d'être
avec nous sur ce plateau avec nous
mathieu quiniou avocat le chercheur
spécialiste des problématiques liées à
l'économie du numérique est donc
toujours au tome abonnés qui nous
accompagne depuis washington civile
d'allemands la lanceuse d' alerte 1
française organes annexes en premier de
facebook assurent donc que le réseau
social affaibli les démocraties rien que
ça c'est très fort comme accusation ça
vous semble pertinent
et pertinents c'est difficile à dire
l'impact des réseaux sociaux devient
majeur dans l'expression démocratique
d'ailleurs lors de sa censure de la loi
à lille le conseil constitutionnel
français parle justement d'un droit
d'accès aux réseaux sociaux
donc il y a un impact majeur sur
l'expression démocratique
après vous il ya quand même une vision
politique
qui n'est pas neutre dans l'appréciation
du rôle de facebook quant à son danger
potentiel au niveau des démocraties
c'est à dire chacun l'interprétera comme
un comme il l'entend
il ya en france notamment le
gouvernement français travaille avec
facebook depuis le 2019 sur la
régulation
de certains messages de ce qu'on
qualifie de fenioux
donc ça s'inscrit dans une démarche
assez longue
aux états unis on a tous le phénomène du
romantisme qui lui aussi vient impacter
cette appréciation de la vérité en fait
on ne fait pas un grand défenseur de
faits de boue mais il faut quand même
reconnaître que chacun a tendance à
orienter
l'impact que pourrait avoir un réseau
social par rapport à ta propre vérité
alors mathieu clean your face again en
tout cas ne soit revenir clairement à
des des réseaux à l'échelle humaine a
dit jusqu'en 2008 ça et s était
acceptable qu'est ce qui a changé
justement depuis les années 2008 2009 ce
sont ces fameux hyper amplificateur qui
favoriserait un discours haineux en tout
cas on est sur des méta plate forme
maintenant et qui sont vraiment
dominante on est passé d'un modèle où
finalement les mass-médias dominé et ces
structures là qui sont des réseaux
sociaux venez progressivement prendre
aussi des départs de marché départ du de
lisibilité mais on a vu par exemple dans
les dernières campagnes présidentielles
la place que représentait les réseaux
sociaux en termes mêmes de limitation de
temps de parole en terme de censure donc
c'est vraiment devenus des acteurs
centraux au niveau démocratique et on
voit aussi la manière dont les marchés
en terme publicitaire aussi vont
s'orienter vers ce type de profil âge
puisque ça permet de toucher une
audience bien plus précise donc c'est
aussi plus intéressant donc ils sont
devenus un élément structurant dans nos
sociétés donc oui en tout cas ce qu elle
pointe du doigt elle sait que facebook
pose délibérément ses utilisateurs à
rejoindre ces grands groupes de
discussion à des à des fins commerciales
et comme elle le dit générateur de
discours haineux est-ce que c'est
véritablement le cas c'est une tellement
c'est difficile à dire encore une fois
doudou en parle c'est à dire qu'un
message et nous c'est très compliqué à
qualifier juridiquement
ça dépend de la personne qu'il
interprète après que facebook isole
volontairement
les utilisateurs dans des groupes
conforme à leur mode de pensée et les
isole les uns des autres pour créer en
fait d espèce de clone qui qui qui
vivrait qu'entre c'est c'est une
évidence et au niveau marketing c'est ça
s'explique très bien puisque ça provoque
au sein de ces groupes des impulsions
d'achat des modes et d'une espèce de
segmentation la consommation
alors autre point de vue qui est un
petit peu discuté qui interroge cette
danseuse éleveurs qui peinent une fois
de plus pour que facebook soit contraint
aussi de rendre publiques les données
qu'il détient justement sur
l'utilisation de son service
clairement on peut parler mathieu qui
doutent d'une entreprise avec un
fonctionnement extrêmement opaque bien
sûr les black box est un vrai souci 1
comprend de l'algorithme de
hiérarchisation aussi comment est ce que
les finalement les profils h ont fait
pourquoi on nous envoie telle ou telle
information avoir une visibilité sur ça
c'est un vrai enjeu est d'ailleurs au
niveau européen on voit qu'à une
recherche de réglementation il ya
une réglementation en cours au niveau de
l'intelligence artificielle qui
toucheraient bien évidemment facebook et
qui permettrait justement de d'éviter
aussi certains usages de l'intelligence
artificielle pour du profilage avec des
billets discriminatoire qui permettrait
d'éviter ce type de choses là et d'avoir
aussi éventuellement une visibilité sur
le code pour que les citoyens puissent
se positionner en et les consommateurs
voilà selon la manière dont on est
appréhendée aussi par ses structures
thomas bonnin washington le rôle de
facebook et est il là bas aussi
régulièrement questionnée en eau aux
états unis
est différente les démocrates comme les
républicains veulent s'attaquer
justement à l'encadrement juridique de
facebook il faut comprendre qu aux etats
unis facebook est régi par une loi qui
s'appelle la section 230 et qui comprend
en fait deux aspects d'abord les
plateformes numériques dont facebook
contrairement aux journaux ne peuvent
pas être tenu responsable du contenu qui
circulent et puis l'autre aspect c'est
qu'elles ont le droit de modérer à leur
guise le contenu en le signal en
ajoutant des investissements etc c'est
sur ce point précisément que donald
trump avait voulu attaquer les
plateformes numériques notamment après
que certains de ces messages a lui été
signalée sur la plateforme twitter alors
que pour les démocrates c'est plutôt le
premier volet de cette loi qui pose
problème car il estime que cela laisse
libre cours à des contenus qu'il
qualifie de désinformation c'est
d'ailleurs aussi ce qui explique la
lanceuse d'alert française à horgen qui
elle aussi veut s'attaquer veut amender
cette cette section de 130 notamment
pour que facebook soit tenu responsable
des algorithmes qui sont utilisées et
qui favorise certains contenus au
détriment d'autres on va aller voir les
premiers messages 1 parce que
comme le disait notre invité tout à
l'heure à cyril d'helmand c'est toujours
du point de vue là on se place les
téléspectateurs eux soulève beaucoup la
question de la censure c'est ce qui
revient dans beaucoup de messages
télégramme envoyé sur le conte
télégramme rt france est un danger car
ce média choisi qui a le droit de parole
et surtout qui oriente l'opinion ce
message avec ses positions et ses
idéologies prompt à la censure est
interdit tout débat pourtant
démocratique le réseau est détourné pour
utiliser et servir de propagande est oui
facebook sont sur tout ce qui sort de
son cercle l'autre jour ils ont censuré
une publication sur trump qui datait
d'il ya un an thomas justement on vous
retrouvera rapidement avant de redonner
la parole à nos invités donald trump a
précisément avaient crié à l'ascension
sur les réseaux sociaux d'où il a été
d'ailleurs banni à tel point qu'il a
lancé sa propre plateforme
oui les républicains aux états unis
parlent beaucoup de la censure des
géants du numérique il faut dire que
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une accélération
ces dernières années sur différents
sujets évidemment sur la campagne
présidentielle américaine sur les
évènements au capitole le 6 janvier
dernier ou encore plus récemment sur le
co vide 19 alors pour les républicains
aux états unis il est clair que les
géants du numérique ciblent davantage
les figures on va dire conservateur
conservative du paysage politique
américain ils ont d'ailleurs déposé un
projet de loi au mois de juillet dernier
justement pour tenter de modifier
l'encadrement de ces médiations opéré
par les plateformes et l'une de leurs
oppositions et notamment pour permettre
de pouvoir contester la décision lorsque
son compte et censuré c'est le cas
donald trump on sait d'ailleurs que
l'ancien président a porté plainte au
mois de juin dernier contre facebook
twitter mais aussi google pour tenter de
récupérer ses comptes vu que ça semble
assez mal embarquée pour lui il a donc
décidé de lancer sa plateforme qui sera
disponible dit on au courant de l'année
2022 il faudra voir si les personnes qui
iront sur la plateforme de l'ancien
locataire de la maison blanche seront
assez nombreux et surtout est ce qu il
s'agira surtout de supporters de donald
trump ou si cette plateforme va aussi
pouvoir convaincre d'autres utilisateurs
merci à thomas bonnet cyril d'allemands
là on en revient c'est des points de vue
ou là on se place mais effectivement
ça en est l'illustration de ce quatre
hommes en fait on a exactement le même
process en france il faut savoir que
facebook juste et j'expliquais travail
avec le gouvernement français depuis
2009 avec une logique de diminution
alors en fait pour contourner l'aspect
censure tout de suite génère un certain
nombre de réactions facebook s'est
orienté sur une limitation de la
viralité autrement dit elle isole un
commentaire un message d'une publication
et diminue la capacité à ce qu'on
appelle dollar partage donc où une
relecture fait baisser le la capacité
virale d'un message et il ya des choix
qui sont clairement affichées à par
facebook tout à l'heure je parlais du
lotissement des ces choix sont clairs
la limite de viralité concernent des
thématiques de société qui sont à
l'immigration l'islam
la gpa la pma on est vraiment dans une
philosophie qui avait assumé en fait par
le réseau social
c'est peu par dans matthieu quinio
comment juridiquement on peut lutter
contre ces travers de censure qui ont
l'air de choquer pas mal d'utilisateurs
la question de la censure se pose
réellement effectivement il ya déjà
quand même un cadre légal qui permet de
lutter contre la censure mais on efface
quand même des nouveaux acteurs et ça
peut passer aussi par un croisement
entre le droit et la normalisation
technique et donc la possibilité
de structurellement regarder ces algues
au rythme là et faire en sorte que à
partir du moment où on va décider que
tel contenu ne devrait plus être publié
parce que il touche à telle ou telle et
telle est l élément parce que y'a acheta
ex-ps et six filles ou des éléments prin
d'excès que ce soit totalement mis de
côté et qu'on ait une vraie lisibilité
donc ça peut être aussi fait
techniquement c'est à dire par des
ingénieurs qui vont regarder le code
audités ça et faire en sorte que soient
compatibles avec le droit alors autres
inquiétudes que soulèvent française au
ghana le porte sur le projet en deux
géants américains dans le métavers sens
on va apprendre à beaucoup parler d'eux
de cela cette doublure numérique du
monde physique où l'entreprise entrevoit
d'immenses possibilités commerciales je
vous propose d'écouter la lanceuse des
vertes
et le métavers est une question très
préoccupante à mon avis je pense que
leur vision d'être au sein de
l'environnement de travail est très
préoccupant ils veulent des capteurs des
micros des systèmes de surveillance mais
imaginez que vous êtes chez vous que
vous travaillez de chez vous et que
votre employeur décide d'être une
entreprise de métaux verre et bien c'est
problématique car vous êtes au sein de
votre cadre personnel hors des micros
pourront être placés dans ce cadre
personnel et c'est un gros problème
la série tellement effectivement ce
metaverse qui nous fait si peur ce qu'on
a raison de s'inquiéter comme un le fait
français sans gaine alors est-ce qu'on a
raison oui on a raison il faut bien
comprendre que la logique du metavers en
fait c'est la numérisation du corps et
une irradiation de l'individu pour
partir c'est le premier pas dans la
logique transhumanistes la disparition
du corps physique
l'englobé l'intégralité des activités de
d'un individu au travers de son clown
numérique est en fait cette logique elle
et elle est très très mercantile parce
que on est sur une belgique d'addiction
c'est à dire que vous passerez des
heures et des heures et des heures au
travers du metavers avec votre double
numérique donc votre avatar numérique et
vous serez totalement isolé du monde
réel cette logique d'isoler l'individu
du monde réel à elle est fondamentale
pour ses réseaux sociaux puisque plus
vous allez passer tente sur le réseau
social plus potentiellement on va
pouvoir vous analysez analyser vos
intentions d'achat deviner vos futurs
achats en fait on va on va réaliser une
carte complète numérique de ce que vous
êtes pour reconnaître un mur que à la
nuit de vous reconnaissez vous même
c'est c'est là où c'est terrible mais on
est on est dans la logique de
l'addiction mais ça veut dire parce que
là vous fait un petit peu peur on a
l'impression d'être dans un vieux film
de enfin d'un vieux un film de science
fiction
ça veut dire quoi qu'on va vivre qu'on
va habiter qu'on va louer des
appartements virtuellement qu'on va
conduire des voitures virtuel le monde
ray
pour mme irles à la saisir un ca c'est
de vous faire rêver votre vie là si on
va au bout de la démarche du metavers
sait faire rêver l'individu une vie qui
est numérique donc il se détache de la
médiocrité de son existence de ces
problèmes du quotidien pour
partir dans un monde virtuel dans lequel
il pourrait être n'importe quel acteur
il pourra vivre une vie totalement
différente s'ils habitent dans une tour
de béton un sens paysage maintenant on
pourra le projeter sur une île
paradisiaque et du coup il aura besoin
pour continuer à vivre cette vie
numérique de pratiquer des achats
tu viens sur ce type de réseaux a pour
vous mettre en place notamment des
voyages virtuels des billets d'avion
virtuelle des voitures virtuel du
carburant virtuel avec une monnaie
virtuelle et vous vivrez dans un rêve
permanent le cannabis est lâché par mois
on aura peut-être plus elle paye et
mathieu quiniou c'est vraiment je dirais
familièrement un petit peu flippant
juridiquement est ce que il ya des
paraphes us qu'on va en arriver là
sans aucun contrepoids juridiques
notamment alors on avait vu par exemple
que le projet libre à qui est devenu
'j'aime a quand même été régulée même
vraiment limité par les américains par
le gouvernement donc ça ça a été mis un
petit peu de côté donc ça aurait été un
pan fait de facebook dans le domaine
bancaire là on arrive sur un autre champ
qui à mon sens relève plus quand même du
loisir qui est moins inquiétant mais
bien sûr des données pourront être
obtenus ça peut toucher au monde du
travail aussi on l'a vu avec les visio
conférences qui se généralise et le fait
finalement d'avoir tout un pan de son
activité qui est devenu entièrement
numérisée et je pense que facebook
regarde de près aussi ce qui se fait au
niveau de l'agglo chain et on a vu
l'apparition à la fois des jetons au
fonds gip dnf t&d métavers décentralisée
et laisser marcher là commence à prendre
et facebook et sait se renouveler sans
aucune réglementation évidemment pour
l'instant il y en a un petit peu c'est
une réglementation des marchés
financiers une règlementation voir aussi
en chine par exemple que le temps
d'usagé pour le loisir sur internet a
été limitée et la chine a une stratégie
aussi à la facebook je sais pas qui
copie qui mais il ya une logique de 10
dans de double numérique qui est
proposée en chine pour faire une sorte
de méta vers cette fois ci ils n'ont pas
contrôlé par un métal une méta
plateforme une entreprise mais parler
mais par un état merci m quiniou merci
cyril également d'avoir été avec nous
verse également notre correspondant à
washington thomas baudet de nous avoir
accompagnés merci à vous trois essais